next global warming myth or reality is
the topic of discussion at a forum
sponsored by the smith college of
washington
you will hear from michael deland he is
the chairman of the white house council
on environmental quality thomas lovejoy
of the smithsonian institution and two
representatives from the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration
the group looks at the greenhouse effect
and the warming of the planet
[Music]
welcome
this is the smith college club's annual
fall forum each year the club
organizes an event organized around an
issue of timely and significant
importance and this year it's global
warming myth or reality
before i leave you with
the
prestigious panel of experts that we've
gathered here this evening
i'd just like to thank a few people
who've helped organize this event first
the other members of the program
committee marian orrin andrea bernardo
shelley sapone for her administrative
support cara polk for her help in
publicizing this event garrett clark for
her behind the scenes organization
and um and agnes bundy who's on the
senate budget committee staff who helped
us get this location
i'd also like to thank daphne gemmell
who for her substantive assistance in
organizing this panel discussion
daphne is a smith grad and a graduate of
yale law school yale graduate school um
daphne
sorry daphne i didn't mean to insult you
daphne has it has an extensive
background
extensive background in environmental
issues and is presently a senior policy
analyst at noaa
i will leave you now in daphne's
competent hands and she will be
moderating this discussion thank you
thank you gina
i want to welcome you to the washington
smith club fall forum
the topic global warming myth or reality
i think is very timely
you've probably seen in the newspapers
headlines that say the average air
temperature worldwide was the warmest on
record antarctica sheds ice and
scientists wonder why threat that global
warming could raise sea levels prompts
calls for intensive monitoring
air pollutant may counter global warming
with all this information though the
public is confused because they hear so
many conflicting reports on global
warming
there is a lot that's known there's a
lot that's not known
scientists politicians and public
interest group representatives agree
that certain gases such as carbon
dioxide and methane trap heat from the
sun that would otherwise escape back
into space causing a greenhouse warming
effect
the scientific controversy arises over
whether humans are hastening this
process and whether these gases known as
greenhouse gases
by preventing the planet from
dissipating heat threaten to change the
climate thereby affecting for example
fisheries agriculture and human living
patterns
the political controversy is whether
steps need to be taken immediately to
avoid the social economic and
environmental consequences of climate
and global change
for the last two decades evidence of
change in the earth system has been
mounting but all the evidence is not in
scientists are undertaking a major
effort worldwide to seek answers to
questions such as sources and sinks of
greenhouse gases which affect
predictions of future concentrations the
role of clouds which strongly influence
the magnitude of climate change and the
role of the oceans which influence the
timing and patterns of climate change
the scientific uncertainty drives the
public policy debate between the camp
which says we know enough to begin to
take steps now to prevent dire
consequences in the future and the camp
that believes more studies are necessary
to know what appropriate actions are
needed whom to believe
we are here tonight to hear from this
esteemed panel whether global warming is
a myth or a reality
at this time i'd like to introduce the
panel members
as a whole
i'd like to start on my far left with
mike deland is chairman of the white
house council on environmental quality
he is responsible for overseeing
implementation of the national
environmental policy act
previously mr deland was new england
regional administrator for the u.s
environmental protection agency and he
has received numerous awards including
the massachusetts audubon society award
for his leadership in cleaning up the
boston harbor
to my immediate left is thomas lovejoy
assistant secretary for external affairs
of the smithsonian institution a
tropical and conservation biologist dr
lovejoy has worked in the brazilian
amazon since 1965.
he serves on numerous scientific
conservation and government bodies
including the president bush's council
on enviro advisors in science and
technology
he is also the founder of the public
television series nature and originator
of the innovative concept of debt for
nature swapping
brave pomerantz on my immediate right is
senior associate with the climate energy
and pollution program at the world
resources institute mr pomeranz was
formerly president and ceo of friends of
the earth and was founder and
coordinator of the national clean air
coalition
he attended the international
negotiations to protect the ozone layer
and is currently an observer to the
intergovernmental panel and climate
change
on my far right is eileen shea a marine
biologist and in the executive sec
director climate and global change
program office of global programs in the
national oceanic and atmospheric
administration or noaa
she has been instrumental in the
development of the us global change
research program she recently completed
her term as executive secretary of the
interagency committee on earth and
environmental science working group on
global change which is under the
direction of the president's office of
science and technology
i have asked ms shea to speak first on
the topic of what we know and what we
don't know
michele thank you daphne
believe it or not
being speaking first and speaking on the
topic of what we know and what we don't
know is in fact the easiest job of all
of the panelists here tonight
because i have the assistance of 170
scientists from 25 countries around the
world
who recently completed a scientific
assessment of what we know what we do
not know about climate change
it's the result of the panel that daphne
referred to just a few moments ago the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change organized in 1988 by the world
meteorological organization and the
united nations environment program
as a mechanism to assess the state of
our understanding of three things
related to climate change one
what is the the state of our scientific
knowledge
about the current state of the earth's
climate system and how it's likely to
change over the next several decades to
a century
secondly the panel was asked to look at
potential impacts of climate change and
thirdly the panel was asked to consider
response strategies
to
predicted changes in climate
for the next five minutes or so i'm
going to run you through quickly the
findings of the first of those efforts
the scientific assessment of what we
know and what we do not know the report
was recently published it will be
presented formally in geneva in about a
week at the second world climate
conference for additional discussion
as i say it's relatively easy to stand
here and tell you what 170 scientists
say because not only did they say it
their work was reviewed by an additional
200 of the world's leading scientists
and what i'm going to be telling you is
essentially the what we believe as a
statement of the scientific consensus of
our understanding
in looking at the title of this session
global warming myth or reality a couple
of things struck me first
first of all there's my initial negative
gut reaction to the words global warming
part in part that's because of my
scientific training which tells me that
we're worried about a lot more in the
global environment than just a potential
warming of the earth's climate system
in part i have to admit that part of my
instinct instinctual gut reaction
relates to the fact that i sit in a
position in a federal agency
and as a result my position on global
warming is is only one part
of a discussion that involves all the
federal agencies the broad academic
community our international partners
and
congress
the fact
is
that the issue of global warming is very
real
the issue that we are potentially facing
dramatic changes in the global
environment is real it's
incontrovertible
land use practices
resulting from growths in human
population the need to clothe and feed
those new individuals on the planet
energy use and the development of
countries around the world
is dramatically changing the face of the
planet the planet is
changing we have recent evidence that
humankind can influence
global environment in dramatic ways that
we had no way of anticipating
the most recent is the antarctic ozone
hole
when scientists suggested that
chlorofluorocarbons or freons
could when
in great enough concentrations in the
atmosphere affect
the levels of stratospheric ozone
they were looking for signals that were
global in scope
nothing in our understanding of the
earth system could have prepared us
for a dramatic house gases
in the atmosphere is increasing
we've all seen the famous carbon dioxide
curb taken from an observatory on the
top of monoloa in hawaii
carbon dioxide is increasing
so are chlorofluorocarbons the freons
the so-called culprits in ozone
depletion which in the lower atmosphere
are also a greenhouse gas no question
the concentrations are going up
similarly another greenhouse gas
methane is increasing in dramatic
concentration
the trouble with methane is that unlike
chlorofluorocarbons which are solely
man-made
and carbon dioxide whose principal
major increase we can trace to human
activities
methane has lots of natural sources and
we're not sure whether the increase in
methane is more a result of natural
changes in the earth system or things
that human beings are doing
well those are the facts we know
for instance that the concentrations of
greenhouse gases are going up
what the ipcc science assessment says is
given
those facts
we've applied the best computer models
that we can find
that represent the best representations
of earth system behavior that we can
find
and we ask those models
what happens to the world
if we double the concentrations
of gas a gas like co2
when you run those models and evaluate
the results the ipcc
science assessment says
that under a scenario that they refer to
as business as usual
which means assume that the
concentrations of of greenhouse gases in
the atmosphere will continue to increase
at roughly the rate at which they're
increasing now
that one could expect to see
a change an increase in the global mean
surface temperature
of three tenths of a degree
per decade
but here's the kicker
with an uncertainty range of between two
tenths of a degree and five tenths of a
degree
centigrade per decade
if you increase global mean surface
temperature at that rate
by the year 2025 the global mean
temperature of the planet will be one
degree centigrade warmer than it is
today
and by the end of the century
the global mean surface temperature
would be three degrees warmer than it is
today
now all of that assumes
that the dominant factor
in climate change of a warming character
is the physics
the radiative physics of those gases and
the behavior of the atmosphere
and in the models that we use to make
those predictions we have included only
a relatively simple ocean
and no biology whatsoever
still in all
it is the best assessment
based on our best understanding
of how the earth system works
one of the most challenging aspects of
this of the results of these computer
models is
that the change is not uniform
by region of the world
ocean
dominant regions of the world like
southern latitudes in these computer
models
don't warm as much
as northern latitudes which are
dominated by land surfaces
the change differs from season to season
the regional detail of our predictions
is extremely limited
and when you begin to think about
building agricultural policy for a given
country for example
you have to want better detail
as we increase
our commitments in the policy arena
that doesn't mean that you don't take
actions
it means that you take actions
and you build into your policy
the constant re-evaluation of scientific
findings and the constant re-evaluation
of policy in light of those scientific
findings
daphne in her opening remarks identified
the principal areas of scientific
research that have to be addressed
because they are the principal factors
that influence
exactly how the earth system as a whole
will respond to change
they are the role of clouds
as one example
a recent experiment by the united
kingdom meteorological office one of the
places in the world that has a computer
that can predict climate change
recently demonstrated that if you change
how you reflect only one earth system
parameter in that model if you change
the way you represent clouds and only
clouds
you can change the predicted warming
by half
similarly
the oceans and the role they play in not
only moving heat around the system but
absorbing carbon dioxide and taking it
out of the global atmosphere the role of
the oceans
is similarly very very difficult to
discern at the moment it's a primary
area of research
just like the experiment where you
change the way you represent clouds
about five years ago a scientist at
princeton
in one of the noaa laboratories decided
gee i'm going to try something
interesting i have a model that has an
atmosphere that moves and i have a model
that has an ocean that moves and i'm
going to run it twice
doubling carbon dioxide
the first time i run it i'm going to let
the system work i'm going to let the
atmosphere move i'm going to let the
ocean move and i'm going to see what
happens he did and he got predicted
changes in warming that are similar to
the ones that i discussed a few minutes
ago and then he tried an interesting
experiment he did what he refers to as
turning the ocean off
basically there was water in the model
but it didn't move
it couldn't take heat and move it
downward vertically in the water water
column of the earth he couldn't move
heat from the poles from the equator to
the poles when he did that he doubled
the projected warming of the planet with
the same increase in atmospheric
concentrations of co2
in both of those cases scientists don't
ask you to believe one or the other
scientists ask you to understand
that we have a hell of a challenge in
front of us
as if it isn't a bad enough challenge to
figure out excuse me how things like
clouds and the ocean which are key
elements of the earth system will react
under quote normal circumstances
the earth system has already told us in
the last five years we better be ready
for surprises and some of them might be
nasty
the ozone hole was a surprise
it was an element of the earth system
acting in a way we didn't know it could
act
the fact is
if the planet is facing
a future in which global
average temperatures surface
temperatures are increasing
and if in fact you assume that the
system
the atmosphere the oceans the biological
communities of the system will react to
that increase
it's very likely that the planet has
several other surprises in store for us
i was talking to tom lovejoy before the
session and being a biologist i like to
think that maybe one of these days we're
going to discover that we're
more relevant to this problem than
several others seem to think we are
sometimes but the fact is
it's possible that it's changes
surprises in the biological communities
that are the ones that are going to wake
us up and make us realize
something that is at the heart i believe
of a program
that builds a science scientific effort
into its heart
and that is
we're not committing to just solving
today's pollution problem
we're committing to a new partnership
with nature that's what's going on on
this planet right now individuals are
committing to it governments are
considering committing to it and the
fact is
we're living in a historic time
this is the time when if you're an
environmentalist for instance
you will see
the culmination of what began in the
late 60s and the early 70s because
children today
know more about the environment and its
problems than their parents
and they are forcing their parents to
learn
and that means we're beginning to make
concerns about our environment an
intrinsic part of who we are
and who we're going to be in the future
thank you
[Applause]
thank you eileen
following on eileen's discussion i asked
our next speaker dr lovejoy to address
the question of the impact of global
warming on one particular area an area
that he is a specialist in biodiversity
well thank you it's great to be here
you know basically it doesn't matter
if we turn up the thermostat on this
planet
unless it affects biological systems
and the problem is
that biological systems are in the end
very sensitive
to
relatively tiny changes
in the physical environment
a lot of reasons to be concerned about
the protection of biological diversity
the variety of plant and animal life on
this planet
that variety with which we share the
experience of being alive
which is as far as we know a great
exception within the universe
even a great exception to the second law
of thermodynamics
one of the reasons
to be concerned about the protection of
biological diversity
is
that each species
has its unique set of biological
properties
which means that each one is
a unique indicator of a kind of
environmental change in the end
the plant and animal species are the
most sensitive indicators we have of
environmental change
and the more we lose
a variety of plant and animal life the
more likely it becomes that the first
species to show indication of
environmental change
will be ourselves
and that is why when scientists who
study frogs all around the world
began to notice that they were dying out
or declining in all kinds of different
places
for reasons that nobody understands as
yet
that it generated a front page story in
the washington post because what that is
telling us is
something is driving environmental
change or some set of things are driving
environmental change that hit biological
systems and we better find out what it's
all about before it hits us
one of the things that is driving
the global climatic change
happens to simultaneously hit biological
diversity
and that is
the
burning of forests
unnatural burning of forests and
particularly of tropical forests
and tropical forests
i mean they really don't occupy very
much of the dry land surface of this
earth only seven percent
uh but they contain somewhere between
fifty and ninety percent of all plant
and animal species
and
there's an embarrassment of modern
science that we can tell you with
astonishing precision
uh
things about how the tectonic plates
move on jupiter or the distance between
the surface of the earth and the moon
but we cannot tell you
to within even an order of magnitude how
many
fellow species of plants and animals
there are
i can't tell you whether it's 3 million
or 30 million
and the major piece of that uncertainty
uh is based on the ignorance about
how many species there actually are in
tropical forests well those forests are
already more than half gone
they're going at
a very rapid rate
which is not precisely measured either
but it's something on the order of 100
acres a minute
and the more conservative estimates are
that we're losing about two-tenths of a
percent of all species of plants and
animals every year because of what's
happening in tropical forests it's a
very conservative estimate
there are other reasons to be concerned
about the loss of biological diversity
other than this indicator function
one is they're full of
very important products
uh
medicine
agriculture
and you name the biological activity
that humans are dependent upon
is continually being enriched and
improved by discoveries of new
properties of systems in nature
and really the third
and related aspect of that is
as
living organisms dependent on biological
systems environmental systems we have a
huge vested interest
in the life sciences and indeed if you
look at the way governments are
constructed
a lot of it has to do with biological
systems there are departments of
agriculture
there are departments of health
there are
forest service
there are fisheries
and you can
keep pushing that point further the
point is
we have
the deepest of vested interests in the
growth of the life sciences and
everything they can mean for us
and every time a species is lost
we lose a set
of
working biological systems
uh they're astonishingly rich in
information and just to give you an
incline
intimation of that
ed wilson the great biologist at harvard
did a little calculation of the amount
of information as a computer would count
it in one strand
of the nucleic acids
one chromosome of a mass and it's
equivalent to all editions of the
encyclopedia britannica combined
so
in the end what is going on is book
burning of probably the greatest sort
ever in our history
and those who sort of sit there and say
uh you know
why worry about a spotted owl and the
old growth forests
are really
unknowingly involved in one of the most
anti-intellectual arguments that you can
possibly dream up
well that's bad enough in itself
but
global climate change is going to
deliver a second body blow
to biological diversity on top of what's
happening in the tropical forests
because these climates are slated for
change
we can't tell you but very much about
what will happen in a particular place
at a particular time as you've heard
which only makes the problem worse
but in the end what we're talking about
probably are rates of change of climate
faster than plant and animal species
have
had to
adjust to
in the natural
recent history of this planet
uh when the climates used to swing back
and forth between
uh times like the current one and
times when the glaciers dominated and
there was a mile of ice or more above
new york city
as those climates swung back and forth
plant and animal species moved up slope
or down slope or north or south or
whatever
interestingly enough we know from
studies of
fossil
ecological
records
that
species living together in a forest
didn't necessarily move together in
response to climate change they moved at
different rates and reassembled in
different kinds of communities
but they did it at rates
that were slower
than those that are projected
so there's considerable question as to
whether plant and animal species can
move as rapidly as climate change is
projected to
in most of the models
and secondly they're going to have to do
it in a landscape unlike any they've
ever had to do that in before i mean
basically they're going to do it in a
man-dominated landscape
a super obstacle course
as a friend of mine said the species
might want to move
but philadelphia will be in the way
so
basically there is a very serious
implication here for the future of
biological diversity
and when you add it all up
unless we change our course which of
course
in the end is why one indulges in these
kinds of discussions
but unless we make certain changes
slow that climate change down
basically we are working up to one of
the greatest
biotic crises ever known in the history
of life on earth
unlike the dinosaurs we'll be doing it
to ourselves
and society will be based on this
strange shifting okefenokee of biology
which probably will have deeply serious
implications
so that's enough for me
[Music]
now that we've heard about some of the
problems i'm hoping mr deland will be
able to outline some of the
administration's efforts on this
important scientific and policy question
thank you daphne it's a pleasure to be
here with you this evening and
with eileen and rafe and
good friend and colleague
tom
i'm glad this is being taped i have to
speak in biological diversity at penn
state later this week and i would like
very much to recycle that
i told my smith spout spouse on
coming in that in deference to this
august audience i would try my best to
be on good behavior
but that pledge uh went out the window
when i saw a college classmate in the
audience and then further when a navy
shipmate uh wandered wandered in late as
as always
but
that said i do appreciate the
opportunity to
discuss this issue uh with you an issue
that is of intense concern
to a president who wants to be known
as the environmental president
recognizing full well that that is not a
title which is
bestowed but rather an honor earned and
earned by hard work over the course of
an administration
it's an extremely complex
issue as eileen has indicated but one
which he and others of us in the
administration
i believe are confronting in a
forthright fashion
before
stating the u.s position
i would parenthetically add that i
recognize
full well
that we have done a less than artful job
of
disseminating
packaging that position and i will
assume a fair amount of responsibility
for that
but that
said and while we clearly don't deserve
any awards for public relations i would
ask for
a fair hearing on
the facts
simply stated the u.s position is that
which secretary baker articulated in his
maiden speech as secretary of
state
which is basically while we
may not know as much as we would like to
know about the
rate or magnitude of global climate
change
what we do know
is that those actions we would take to
ameliorate it
are those that make common sense for
ancillary reasons and so
let's get on with them
those actions include
energy efficiency
both ongoing efforts and those that will
be
shortly outlined as part of the
forthcoming national energy
strategy
standards for federal
commercial buildings
lighting
innovations
the list
goes on
the federal government clearly ought to
be in the vanguard on that and we
are trying to position ourselves with
not the alacrity that i would like to
see
and some of the rest of us would but
nonetheless trying to position ourselves
as
leaders
in that movement
that said
the private sector is
happily moving and
aggressively so
and what we're
seeing is a happy confluence of
environmental and economic interests
it's increasingly demonstrated that it's
in the economic
interest
of the private sector of the public
sector to be energy
efficient
on the west coast for example on pacific
gas and electric
over the course of the last decade has
saved some 1300 megawatts of power
while saving their consumers somewhere
between
three to four billion dollars by
energy efficiency measures
for the coming decade they have
forecasted energy efficiency savings in
the order of 2500 megawatts
not in substantial amount
here on the east coast the new england
electric system is doing much the same
thing
in an alliance that would have been
unlikely if not unholy as recently as
several years ago
they with the conservation law
foundation and with
ceq in a catalytic role
have engaged in the re-lighting of
federal buildings in new england one
that is underway at this very moment is
the re-lighting of the andover irs
building the largest irs facility
in new england
the new england electric system has
found that energy efficiency component
of its operation is its biggest money
maker so clearly in its economic
interest as well
as its environmental interests and
attempt to be a good corporate citizen
to move and move aggressively in that
area
similarly increased emphasis on
renewable sources of energy has got to
be a major part of the equation
phase out of cfcs which the u.s has been
a leader and to which we have committed
to phasing out completely by no later
than the year 2000 the clean air act
which i'm
happy to say
that as of this moment appears although
i have not read it line by line to be a
bill which the president can indeed sign
and one which after a 13-year
hiatus
will indeed
move this country
in a direction that it has uh
long uh needed to proceed in
that
statute will reduce uh numbers of the
greenhouse gases uh co2 vo vocs so2 and
the like reforestation the president is
committed to a
program america the beautiful by name of
planting 1 billion trees
a year
for the next decade
an enormous sink to assume
much of the greenhouse gas emissions
in the
aggregate these efforts that are
underway will reduce
greenhouse gas emissions in this country
by approximately 25 percent
from projected levels by the year 2000.
few if any
nations in this world can document and i
stress can document a
better record
historically we haven't fared as badly
as some would lead us
to believe
co2 emissions for example have been
essentially stable
over the course of the last 20 years
during the time while the economy grew
by 75 percent our population increased
by some 22 percent
in the energy arena
energy use per unit of gmp
has fallen 28
since the early 1970s
now clearly not as fast to fall as many
of us would like to see but nonetheless
a trend in the right direction
at the same time the united states has
ended up
570 million dollars in this fiscal year
with another
billion dollars
projected
budgeted for the forthcoming fiscal year
for global climate change research
far far more than any nation
on the face of this earth and in fact i
think it's fair to say that the
deliberations worldwide that are ongoing
right now
are
predicated if not exclusively almost
solely on u.s or u.s funded research
by way of comparison
prime minister thatcher
recently established a global climate
change
office in england to which she dedicated
the equivalent of 10 million dollars
not the 570 million that we've spent
already the billion that we are to spend
this coming year but
10 million dollars
well where does this leave us
not only here in this country but
worldwide
in 1950
the united states to just pick one
indicia
generated 45
of the global co2 emissions
today
that number is approximately 23
by the turn
of the century if the developing world
develops as projected and as we'd all
like to see
that number will dwindle into the single
digits
so we in this country from a statistical
standpoint will become comparatively
insignificant
the real challenge
is how china
will use that coal pile upon it which it
sits how india will develop its energy
resources how eastern europe develops
how latin america develops and clearly
we have a
challenge
and a responsibility
to see that those areas of the world
do not replicate the mistakes that we
know so well
in this country
and to the to the degree that we are
successful by the transfer of technology
by the infusion of dollars
where appropriate it is that that will
determine the rate magnitude of global
climate change now clearly that said
we have a responsibility to
cleanse our hands here in this country
to
show the show the way to ever more
aggressively uh pick up the pace on some
of the measures which i have just uh
mentioned as eileen noted at the outset
we are wedded to the ipcc process
under the auspices of the u.n and have
agreed to host the first negotiating
session this coming february
toward a framework
convention
under that
body
so clearly a
challenge of
tremendous magnitude but one that we
simply
cannot
for our sake more importantly for the
sake of our kids and kids around the
world do anything less than confront in
a forthright and
aggressive fashion thank
[Applause]
you our final speaker of the evening mr
pomerantz will discuss the environmental
community's views on the question before
us global warming myth or reality
thank you daphne
let me uh first uh
i guess deal with the topic of the
evening myth of reality and go back a
little bit uh
back to 1979
and the science of this question because
it helps i think helps to clarify
how strong the consensus is in the
scientific community
1979 the president's science advisor of
the time asked the national academy to
review the greenhouse issue
and give him an assessment of
best science of the time
and the uh conclusion of that nas panel
was that the earth when
the level of carbon dioxide the major
greenhouse gas was doubled in the
atmosphere
that the earth would warm three degrees
centigrade plus or minus one and a half
degrees or one and a half to four and a
half degrees centigrade or about three
to eight degrees fahrenheit
since that that was a national academy
assessment and the academy reported that
they had looked for ways around the
problem
sort of looked it over turned over all
the rocks and couldn't find a way around
it
they asserted at the time there were two
major uncertainties which eileen has
referred to the behavior of clouds which
accounts for most of the uncertainty in
their numbers because clouds can either
add to the greenhouse or reduce it
and the oceans which serve as a
delaying factor we put up the gases but
we don't see the effects for some time
due to an ocean lag
since that time
the science has been reviewed
internationally domestically over and
over again a few
new issues have emerged
but on the whole the ipcc panel that has
been referred to here
came to basically the same conclusion
and in the interim the department of
energy even 1985 produced a five volume
study called state of the art on the
greenhouse came out the same way
in viloc austria 1985 a group of
scientists preceding the ipcc also
saw the same results
the reason is it's a very clear problem
it's well understood that
the earth's temperature is controlled by
the content of the atmosphere carbon
dioxide and other gases trap
solar radiation which is reflected off
the earth's surface earth re
sends back radiation in different
wavelength that in turn runs into the
atmosphere and the atmosphere heats up
without the greenhouse we'd be 30
degrees centigrade colder or more
and as we increase greenhouse gases the
the fate of the planet is
scientists believe will be to warm up
how significant are these numbers in
historic terms well a two degree warming
which most people believe or many
believe that we already have in the bank
no matter what we do the change in the
atmosphere has already been so
substantial that we've probably got on
the order of two degrees centigrade the
earth hasn't been two degrees centigrade
warmer for two million years since the
start of the interglacial glacial cycle
that we're now in
a four degree warming which we could be
committed to in another 30 or 40 years
might take us back 40 million years
six degrees which under business as
usual scenario is not out of the
question by the latter part of the next
century could take us quickly back to
the the cretaceous period the age of the
dinosaurs
in other words in a century
or a little more so well it was really
built up since the industrial revolution
but the amount of emissions now is so
large compared to the early years it's
really a recent phenomena we can
transform the earth's climate on that
order of magnitude
and
it you cannot find
scientists really very many of them who
disagree with the direction the debate
tends to be over the magnitude and it's
usually stated in a kind of a
three degrees plus or minus a degree and
a half for doubling but
we are likely to go past doubling
because we have so much momentum in the
system particularly in terms of global
energy use
well are there any what's the major sign
that people are looking for to confirm a
signal
that has to do with a global temperature
record and
the best records that we have show that
the earth has warmed up about a half a
degree
c in the last century
and about half of that in the last 30
years
that's not a definitive signal but it's
consistent
the 1980s were the warmest decade in the
last hundred
and nineteen ninety is running above any
year in the 1980s
1988 was the warmest year in the record
before
let me just uh outline the international
context of the issue what are
governments doing where does it stand
well as panelists have indicated first
thing was done in fact it started two
years ago the day after the presidential
election was the formation this
international study body the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change to do an assessment that's now
complete it will be presented next week
or the week after the second world
climate conference in geneva
negotiations on a convention
will start in february as mike indicated
here in washington on a convention
uh on on this problem
ultimately to achieve global perhaps
global limits on emissions of greenhouse
gases
secondly governments of the world have
already agreed this june to eliminate
chlorofluorocarbons which are about 20
percent of the greenhouse problem they
eliminated them because
chlorofluorocarbons have been confirmed
to be destroying the ozone layer but
they are an extremely powerful
greenhouse gas
and
eliminating them is a by far the fastest
most cost effective way to reduce
the rate of growth of greenhouse gases
in the atmosphere so that's a big plus
but there's something else going on
which is
equally profound
individual governments are making
commitments to control carbon dioxide
the chief greenhouse gas
co2 is the major byproduct of fossil
fuel use anytime you burn oil coal or
natural gas the major byproduct is
carbon dioxide that's what you want and
on the on earth today we produce about
six billion tons of carbon as carbon
dioxide i'm sure the largest waste
product that there is
about two and a half years ago in an
international conference in toronto the
conferees made up of governments
non-governmental organizations called on
the industrialized countries primarily
to lead the way by establishing targets
for co2 the chief greenhouse gas of 20
percent reduction by the year 2000
well as of today in fact
all the major governments in oecd have
announced targets
except the united states
the
european community will meet on monday
to attempt once again to arrive at a
european community target
and
today's announcement came from the
japanese
uh japan
announced the target uh on it
i suppose we should call it as a target
to achieve
a
something between zero growth and five
percent growth over the next 10 years
that's the high end of targets that have
been announced the german government has
announced that in
what was west germany there would be a
25 percent reduction by
i think 2 000 and
i forget the date 2010
which is a huge uh attempted cut
so there is movement
in the industrialized world
uh in a very rapid rate and next monday
if the european community makes a
decision that will
close loop and eventually the united
states will presumably
perhaps as a result of the national
energy strategy come to a decision on
its own target and timetable for co2
policy we do not have a co2 policy in
this country other than what mike
uh
enumerated which is basically you look
at the existing policies you're putting
into effect and see what result they
have you don't make policy on the basis
of climate there's a philosophic
difference there in the other
governments they're making these
targeted decisions because they believe
that the climate issue is a real problem
u.s government i think's position will
be at the second world climate
conference it's premature to set targets
and timetables
although if there are decisions we're
making for other reasons that have a
beneficial impact we will take those and
those can be significant
now what are some of the sort of uh
energy policies we might have to put
into place in order to deal with our own
emissions in a significant way they are
tough decisions
uh
we have to improve the fuel economy of
our automobiles there was a fuel economy
bill on the senate floor this year but
it
could not
uh
was up against the filibuster and didn't
have the votes to uh had 57 votes not
enough to proceed past that obstacle
we've got to significantly shift
our research and development into energy
efficiency energy conservation away from
a coal-based research program coal is
the
has the largest amount of co2 per unit
of energy
of all the fossil fuels about double
that of gas
but basically most of our highest
percentage of our energy research
dollars go into clean coal technology
mike indicated a lot of utility reform
is very exciting the way utilities are
regulated now
public service commissions are giving
financial rewards for conservation
investments
and that is really a revolution in the
making
most significantly
we have to reprice energy
we have to get the market to send a
signal of all the costs not just those
it takes to produce energy but the
environmental costs and that will
probably mean
if it can come about as some form of
carbon tax in which fuels are taxed
according to their greenhouse impact
and that would then lead to some fuel
switching
and reduction
in
emissions and you can the way to do it
perhaps in this political climate is to
put on a tax on
carbon and reduce payroll taxes so you
deal with
any
progressive taxation issues and you have
a revenue neutral approach
you also deal with a lot of the economic
overall impacts on gnp that way
finally a
a strategy of
of uh national energy conservation a
consciousness
where the entire populace somehow is
motivated to look for every savings
that's out there i've been looking in my
house i've found a lot it's kind of fun
very satisfying to see my own electric
bill declining my gas bill declining
and
i think every
every citizen has got to get involved in
saving energy and we've got to give
people the right information the right
incentives to do that
and a lot of the studies that are going
on show that reductions in carbon
dioxide through the use
of energy conservation measures end up
saving individuals in the economy as a
whole money as a whole a lot of money
because there are a lot of steps out
there that are very cost effective
now
mike indicated what are united states
we've got a big problem because
third world countries are are growing
very rapidly they're going to become a
larger portion of the problem
and that is very key that the role of
technology transfer financial assistance
to third world countries to go on a
different energy path is a key part of
the policy
but i don't think that should let us
get away from the fact that the united
states is as mike said about 23 of the
co2 problem
and our share has not declined for the
last 10 years it's been about that level
we use per capita or we produce five
tons of carbon per person
we the canadians and what was east
germany
japan which announced its policy today
produces two tons of carbon per capita
sixty percent less than we in the united
states do
all of europe there's no country that's
over three tons of carbon per person
so we
bear a special
uh
we have a special role to play we are
the largest per capita users in the
world really and we are by far the
largest user
nationally
and uh
unilateral action without support of
others is no longer available that
leadership role has been closed because
other governments are moving rather
rapidly on this problem problem many
have announced goals
many are now moving on to the specific
measures to implement those goals
hopefully hopefully the national energy
strategy
can combine that was started two years
ago combined with a crisis in the
persian gulf
combined with the greenhouse
will bring about a presidential
initiative of some substance on energy
policy
early next year
because i think with the clean air act
now
hopefully will be approved by congress
a lot of attention will shift on the
atmospheric issue to
bringing together the greenhouse which
is fundamentally an energy problem
with a national energy strategy and
combined with our national security
problem the persian gulf we have to
blend all those issues together
and get a national policy out of it the
way to do that
it seems to me the most efficient way is
through changing energy prices that's
not easy politically and it may be that
some kind of revenue neutral approach
could
pull it off thank you
[Applause]
now that we've heard from all the
panelists i'm sure many of you must have
some questions that you would like to
ask them so i'd like to open it up now
to questions for our remaining period of
time yes
two questions um one is i wasn't clear
about what you said about the owl in the
northwest could you just enlighten me on
that one and the second question is
um
are we making any efforts to get away
from
dependence on oil which would have many
many many benefits
i'd like to ask the panelist to repeat
the question in case you couldn't hear
it in the back and i think the first one
was
tom
the question was about my sort of
passing reference to the spotted owl and
the old growth forests of the northwest
this has been largely portrayed in
the press uh
and by the industry involved
uh as
a nice fluffy little owl that some
people like versus uh
you know
000 jobs i think is the larger
estimate of the economic activity that's
currently based on those all-growth
forests
the point i really wanted to make is
it's not a choice between an owl and
jobs in the end
it's a choice between old growth forests
which are a dwindling resource
on which
that industry depends
and will ultimately
run out
the choice between
the old growth forests
[Music]
and all the values that they contain
and all the values they contain is a
whole host of species of plant animals
that only occur in those forests and
will be gone if all the old growth
forests are are timbered
uh
and all the things about biological
diversity that i sort of got into
and i haven't even touched on the sort
of
aesthetic
and other qualities which are important
things to think about i mean
those who sit there and say well do we
really need all those species are in a
sense
asking the same question as
is 104 symphonies of haydn too many
and do we really need them all
the next question was uh are we
moving away uh from our dependence on on
oil and the answer to that is
clearly yes
not only does it make
environmental sense
makes economic sense but it's also as
we've seen dramatically over the course
of the last uh several months it's a
question of international and national
security so yes we we do have to be
moving and moving aggressively in that
fashion to develop
the reserves of natural gas which are
abundant in this country to
re-emphasize the renewables
solar wind
biomass and so forth so yes we are if i
may just amplify daphne mayer for a
moment on something that two things that
rafe said uh one i uh heartily
endorse uh his
charge to us all
to
act in a far more
uh environmentally sensible fashion as
individuals that yes we have the
globalization of these environmental
problems on the one hand but if they're
to be solved it comes down to a personal
level to you and me and how we conduct
our lifestyles and what kind of example
we as individuals and ultimately as a
nation uh set for the rest of the
of the world and we are clearly as he
said the most energy inefficient
country of the industrialized countries
on this earth and it's no
coincidence
that our toughest economic competitors
the japanese and the west germans are
approximately twice as energy efficient
as as are we
that said i think we
need to take with some
caution
the
commitments
that he enumerated that other countries
have made
towards a specific reduction of co2 by a
date certain the japanese commitment for
example which was
just announced within the last day and i
learned of it when coincidentally i was
in admiral watkins
office uh this noon discussing the
development of the national energy
strategy and so we
uh called various uh sources in the in
the japanese uh government and the
answer
at the outset was encouraging yes they
they are committed to this that they're
to get there
fifty percent
by conservation
and fifty percent
by
reliance on nuclear power building of
new nuclear power plants
on the
face of it given what we know about the
burning of of fossil fossil fuels and
the fact that perhaps
someday we can come to grips with a
nuclear disposal problem that seem to be
all right when you dig beneath it one
further question well what's what's the
sighting process and how many plants do
you need the answer was
well we need
over a hundred our current estimate is
109
nuclear power plants in japan
to reach that number and then the next
question is well what are your plans to
cite them
well we know we can't cite 119 nuclear
power plants in japan and we can't build
them so
clearly
that
commitment
which
appears on its face
to be
of
some responsibility when you get get
beneath it uh
has a different light similarly the the
west germans have made commitments how
how are they going to reduce uh their
emissions
one of the large large ways is tapping
into french nuclear power we in this
country don't have that option and it's
for that reason that the united states
or those reasons the united states
is being cautious about committing to
specific reductions by a date certain we
are as i said committed
under the ipcc process to
enter in to negotiations to lead the
negotiations to see what the science
shows and to see what we can indeed
achieve and clearly we've got to be more
aggressive in undertaking the measures
that i outlined earlier but i think we
need to approach with
some
skepticism the
resounding political crise in the
international
circle it's easy for any other
government to commit to targets and
timetables knowing that the united
states
is
not going to make that move and then
they knowing that it likely won't happen
internationally and i hear that from
every single environmental minister that
cycles through my office as they do when
they come to town that as long as the
united states is is not not moving well
it's fine they can beat up on us in any
form they'll find and and they can do so
but they're they're not confronted with
a tough tough uh questions
yeah i i agree with mike he said it was
important to reduce our oil consumption
but i think that we're relying
the only mechanism in place
new mechanism in place is the rise in
oil prices that took place
because of the persian gulf situation
the only
there have been two
uh
policy measures that have been discussed
one is the fuel economy legislation
which is the only significant one
of the
in that would have a large impact i
think
that was as i mentioned did not pass the
filibuster test and
the administration was opposed to it
secondly which administration has
supported
has been a modest increase in the gas
tax but i think it's so small that we
really have to enlarge a debate in
europe
all those
unserious governments
have gas prices that are double triple
quadruple rs
and they've managed they have
they know how energy dependent they are
and they have a completely different
pricing system
as far as skepticism
toward other governments decision
on their goals for co2
i think what's happening is that with
government a lot of governments have
announced goals administration is quite
right say well you announced the goal do
you really mean it
well measures are being announced the
carbon tax
in the netherlands the carbon tax in
sweden
uh the danes have set a goal of 50
reduction they've got measures
uh
it's mixed and more and more countries
are announcing measures it's good for
the united states to say hey where are
your measures the problem will be if all
of a sudden they show up with a complete
list of measures
are we ready i don't think the president
has asked his cabinet for a group a set
of co2 options to date
we have a national energy strategy but i
don't think there's ever been an
explicit question asked
give me a set of options for u.s
national co2 policy maybe there has that
would be encouraging
uh that question has been posed rafe yes
and is there a deadline
within the context of the strategy well
that's encouraging
another question
yes this
is comrades and
mr deland would you please care to
comment on the u.s role at the second
world climate conference
well i think the us has simply
there's been a sort of a dispute about
who whether
which official should go and what does
that mean in terms of the united states
you know was symbolic of whether reilly
goes or canals to head of no i don't
think that's terribly important i think
what we have to say is important
and from what i understand we will
remain consistent on that and one
controversy will be at the second world
climate conferences should there be
targets and timetables
i think what we will say well mike can
clarify this obviously uh right up to
the minute is something like
we ought to handle any negotiations of
target and timetables in the in the
negotiations of a uh
an agreement
that in the convention that those
negotiations will begin in february
and uh
the europeans and others will say let's
all declare targets now i mean there's a
tension in the process and attention
continues to build and we'll go on until
really what's going on is the early
stages of a negotiation
and i don't think our government knows
what it's willing to
to agree to
either in those negotiations we want a
framework convention which implies no
commitments to co2 reduction but i think
we recognize now that's going to be a
topic in the negotiations and perhaps
we will have to agree to something
in those negotiations
rafe has articulated our position
remarkably uh well
uh we we will be represented uh at the
meeting by eileen's boss dr canaus the
administrator of
noah who has represented us at previous
international
meetings the
ministerial declaration
that a group of us
approved this very afternoon
coincidentally
will
serve as a bridge
to the
ipcc meetings which we will host here in
washington in
february we will not
commit to a
specific reduction by a date
certain at this upcoming meeting but are
committed to entering into an honest
negotiation uh process
uh through or under the auspices of the
ipcc and as we glean more
by way of scientific
information what the what the
ramifications
may be from an economic uh standpoint
and many of the other imponderables uh
then clearly as as time goes on i think
we're going to get uh further uh towards
uh committing to what's already underway
and we we right right now
by the year 2000 will reduce our
greenhouse gas gas emissions by uh 25
from projected levels what we're
unwilling to do is to to set that
forth uh in a specific international
document there are many others that say
well let's set a goal but if we miss it
nobody can take us to the world court
and sue
well we view international commitments a
bit differently and want to proceed in
in a responsible and measured pace and
that's the course that we're on let me
just say one one thing about this 25
number we may hear a lot more just that
it
there's just one distinction to make
which is that that number includes our
commitment to reduce cfcs entirely which
are about 20
of the total problem and probably 80
percent of that number the 25 percent
when other governments are committing to
co2 targets they're talking about co2
and they're not counting their
commitments to cfcs
mike
you pointed out and it sounded very
encouraging to me that
the u.s share of global emissions should
be
below 10 by the year 2000 if i
understood it correctly
by extrapolation that would mean the
developed world would be probably 30
which would mean that the third world
then in fact is the major risk we're
looking at 60 70 percent of global
emissions coming from the third world
now i know we recently approved that
slush fund for uh
transfer technology to the third world
but frankly that seems like a pretty
meager effort
on what ought to be done i mean this is
the majority of the
this is the problem what are we doing
what can we do about the third world
problems
but it is the heart of the problem uh
wally there's there's no question about
it and my my figures for under 10 were
early in the next century and whether
it'll be by the turn of the decade or by
25 or 2010 i'm not sure but in in that
uh range uh what we have to do
in my judgment is to transfer
technology
to the chinese india's the rest of the
of the developing world
and
to
lay down dollars on on the table uh when
when we can
in a period of clearly uh as we are
hearing down these very halls uh this
very evening of real financial uh
trouble in this in this country
that we are transferring monies um to
the hungaries and poland and some to
some to china not in the
amounts that that you or i would like to
see
also the the private sector is beginning
to move and move
aggressively recognizing that there's
money to be made
in the developing world but
a component of that private sector
realizing that there's there's money in
the energy of energy efficiency
arena now once again the the japanese uh
moving more aggressively than we are
west west germans uh
tough tough competitors there but our uh
utilities uh are picking up the pace and
substantially so now that's in and of
itself uh not the answer but it's a it's
a piece of it
i think tom would like to comment on the
question yeah i just uh
would like to take this opportunity to
remind us of the role that population
growth
plays in all of this
and i mean the numbers are pretty
terrifying it's essentially 100 million
more people every year
it is nonetheless important to remember
that it is also impact per capita that
counts and you know we are far and away
uh the worst in the industrialized world
from that point of view
i mean very very difficult topic and
people
like to avoid talking about it and dance
around it
but i
simply see no way to deal with any of
the major environmental problems unless
we struggle to come to grips with that
i'd like to direct some questions
there's mounting evidence suggesting
that sulfur dioxide is a main cause or
passive rain may in fact
diminish the effects of global warming
if there is such a global warming taking
place and how do you address such a
problem on the policy side of it are you
gonna also
encourage the increase of co2 level
sulfur dioxide levels
to counteract global warming along with
the encouragement of decreasing co2
levels there seems to be a big problem
there as far as environmentalists go
and what they want to encourage as as
policy goes
the
question is do
sulfates which are a byproduct
precursor of sulfates which is so2
and which is regulated under the acid
rain provisions
of the clean air act that's about to
pass
those offset some of the global warming
as some scientists think might be the
case
the basic problem is that aerosols of
which sulfate is one
uh
can reflect light as it's coming down to
the earth
and act sort of the same as low-level
clouds
and therefore reflect light and diminish
the amount of global warming that's
taking place at any time so the question
is have sulfates
from pollution
mass some of the global warming that we
might otherwise see
second problem is that sulfates also can
the theory goes
help form clouds by forming cloud nuclei
the
i think that the answer is that the
general estimates if that were the case
it would be a portion
anywhere from a few percent to
as much as a half
that the outside estimates nobody really
knows eileen might want to take a crack
at this nobody knows because we don't
have the satellites to tell us
how big the aerosol component is at this
time
but the difficulty is that sulfates live
for a couple of days in the atmosphere
carbon dioxide lives for a couple of
hundred years or stay it lives as the
wrong word remains in the atmosphere so
that if you were to stop burning fossil
fuels the sulfates would fall from the
lower atmosphere and you'd be left with
a 200 year blanket of carbon dioxide
you'd have a huge global warming pulse
now i think what really makes sense is
let's presume that this were the case is
that
you would you have to com
would you have to acidify the
environment in some sense to prevent
global warming
maybe you look at the other side is that
if you have the right kind of energy
policy you can
bring down so2 at the same time as
you're bringing down carbon dioxide
that's the kind of policy we advocate
which is to look at all the problems in
an integrated way
choose those solutions some of which are
incorporated in the clean air act that
will go in the right direction on both
counts
and
that's really the challenge that's
before us you know i think that the
sulfate controversy is really there's
not a lot known about it's a theory and
eileen you want to come in i'm just
going to add one thing
i think the
real
potential for for uh
what's referred to as a negative
feedback with respect to sulfur is
really in in terms of sulfur forming
cloud condensation nuclei it is just a
hypothesis
um but it is one of the primary program
elements in the research program that
michael deland referred to
as being funded as part of the u.s
global change research program literally
our our primary focus at the moment is
to find out just how efficient
sulfur
compounds
are at forming cloud condensation nuclei
and how how does how predominant is that
as a global
activity or is it a process that's very
limited in scale and therefore not
likely to have global effect
and tom wanted to address this question
yeah
i'm reminded
about 20 years ago
evelyn hutchinson
who probably will turn out to be
the most important ecologist in the
history of the science in part because
of his incredible mind but also in part
because when he lived in the development
of that science
made in a sense one of the most
depressing statements i've ever heard
about all of this
which was he did hope that the various
things we were doing to the atmosphere
would cancel each other out
think there is a natural human tendency
to hope that we are going to find
something of this sort which is going to
uh
in the vernacular of my generation
help us luck out of the situation
the chances are that almost any of these
little fixes
are going to have other ecological
effects as well whether it's the effects
of acid rain in this case
or something else and
i mean i'm sure it's one of the problems
that mike struggles with all the time
that people are coming with you know
easy
seeming answers
which in fact may
have all kinds of side effects that you
can't
judge in advance so in the end i don't
think there is any real way out
other than to reduce our pollution of
the atmosphere
i would just underscore what what tom
has
said i i agree heartily with that there
is no
quick
fix
no easy answer i mean some
look at the man-made contributions which
are under five five percent and say
well let's deal with the 95 percent
and hence have to make a far
lesser percentage change than if you
were dealing with the the five percent
that we human beings create and yet
once you start to do that you're
tinkering with that uh remarkable
balance that mother nature has
had going for
many many
uh
millions of years and finally i think
that rafe
pointed out a
key component when he said that we
needed and i believe is where it was
integrated or comprehensive approach and
that clearly in my judgment is what what
we need to do we need to look at our
environment in a holistic
sense but specifically on this
particular
issue that the u.s position is one of a
comprehensive approach looking at all
greenhouse gases and all sources and
sinks of those
gases in the aggregate rather than just
focusing on co2 or and methane or any
individual ones and i think if we do
that they will find that there can be
some
rather
happy
trading situations emerge worldwide that
will
or could well ameliorate the problem
the title of this program was
global warming
miss or reality
and
quite frankly at this stage in the
evening
i haven't yet heard the panel's answer
to that question
they are all talking about
the need for various uh
reforms in our ecological policies and
that may all be good and valid
but whether in fact there is such a
phenomenon as global warming
and if there is whether that's a danger
has been answered the president at some
recent occasion when he was asked about
it said he was not convinced that this
existed and he was unwilling to take a
particular position on that because he
said the scientific evidence was not yet
in that this phenomenon was in fact
occurring that there was equal evidence
that there was a cooling and that if one
looked at all the temperature in the on
the earth in the last 90 years one could
not demonstrate that there had been any
global below global warming i just
thought that since that was the
program title we might get a response to
that question
those of us in government are artful
dodgers
[Laughter]
well my crack would be that i i don't
think as much as
each of us would like to
answer that question with some
specificity that that we can i i don't
think that we have and here i'm speaking
as a layman lawyer in scientific areas
but i don't think we have enough
scientific evidence upon which to answer
uh that question with any any
specificity you you look at the
some of the debate as recently as as 20
years ago and there were many scientists
some of whom are are now
in the forefront of espousing uh global
warming as as upon us or or soon to come
who were predicting the coming of the
next ice age
20 years ago and the the science uh from
what i have been able to
glean through the translation of
alan bromley the president's science
advisor and and others uh simply is not
uh yet here to be able to answer that
question with the certainty that any of
us would would like
well first of all i mean one has to say
there is a greenhouse effect i mean
that's sets the normal temperature of
the earth
question is
has it already started to warm because
of human influence
the the jury is out on that because you
don't have a long enough
string of data
you're looking at at weather
and trying to deduce whether there is
climate change
when you nonetheless look at
the molecules their properties and
the increase in their concentration in
the atmosphere
you end up with
a very strong probability statement that
it's going to cause warming
and
whatever the recent warm years
may mean we won't know for a long time
as to whether that's the beginning of
that warming or not and what the lags
will be in the system
uh
as uh one of my friends in the senate
likes to put it
if you were going to have dinner in a
restaurant and were told there was a one
in four chance you get
botulism would you go
i think a questioner
heard a
rather clear-cut
version well i guess that was one of the
moments a clear-cut picture of the
administration's policy i mean
administration science
represented by the president is at odds
that statement is clearly at odds
with the conclusion
of the global scientific panel the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change that is the biggest source
of the policy that that results in a big
source of policy disagreement
and uh
i think that the scientists who've
looked at this
all predict that the earth will warm and
it's based on the fundamental physics of
increasing the gases in the atmosphere
that trap radiation
there is not agreement that the
temperature increase that has already
occurred in the last hundred years that
it's been observed is a signal
that that change in the radiative
balance of the earth
is showing up in the global temperature
record it may be but nobody agrees
i think
where this argument might best rest is
that the change in the concentration of
these gases already is the equivalent
of increasing the power of the sun
if you were to leave the gas the same
and turn up the sun you'd have already
turned it up since the industrial
revolution by one percent
and it will go up another percent by
2030.
the doubling of co2 maybe it's more than
that it's doubling of co2 i think is 4
4 watts per square meter which is a two
percent increase in the power of the sun
same thing so in a way you could argue
yeah the greenhouse effect has already
begun simply because
the radiative
the the concentration of these gases in
the atmosphere has already taken place
and remember
that when the earth went from an ice age
to today's interglacial it changed about
the same order of magnitude the global
temperature warmed up eight degrees
and we've already changed the earth
about in the same order of magnitude a
little bit less so
it's a significant change in the
atmosphere already what we haven't
confirmed is that the warming we've seen
so far is that signal
but i think the vast majority of
scientists believe that the earth will
warm and do so significantly that's the
conclusion of this panel that we helped
start two years ago
well at this point just about
everything's been said about about the
issue the the fact is
that
we can't tell you whether a human ex
an acceleration
of global warming due to human
activities
is real because the record of data
doesn't allow us to tell you that
definitively in other words
the observations don't exist
for me to stand up in a court of law and
say
we've seen it it's here they just don't
exist
what's what you're seeing and and part
of the frustration of of saying well why
can't we get an answer to the question
that was posed to the panel is
we're talking about major changes in the
way we live on this planet
and we're talking about making them
before we even know what the results of
making them will be we are making
policy
in
an era of uncertainty we have to do that
because we're talking about the future
not the past
until the record shows whether there has
been an accelerated warming that can be
indisputably linked to the increase in
concentration of gases that we know
exists
we have to be willing to debate the
issue
knowing the uncertainty and
acknowledging that we're making
decisions based on that
uncertainty it's likely according to the
ipcc science assessment that it'll be
more than a decade before we can even
begin to hope to look at an
observational record of temperature
change for example and indisputably say
human induced global warming is here
instead what you're hearing is we have
to take the best scientific information
we have available we have to make
decisions and we have to commit
ourselves to constantly re-evaluate
those decisions
because this is not a quick fix
problem this is the future of our
partnership with this planet
i'm afraid
if i may just
okay i was just going to say i'm afraid
we've run out of time and it's an
excellent question to end on but i will
let you have a few more minutes
i'll just quick quickly amplify by
saying that that indeed is so that we
are confronted with decision making in
the face of uncertainty as is
always the case or inevitably the case
in the scientific arena but common sense
says that if we continue to pour co2
into the atmosphere at the rate that
we're doing that the earth is going to
warm we're not quite sure how fast and
what the what the rate will be
so then common sense says to me
that we ought to be moving and moving
aggressively
to ameliorate that and through the steps
that again predicated on common sense uh
are are sensible for for other ancillary
uh reasons and that uh to me
is a policy if
if pursued aggressively
that
is uh makes common sense to me and one
in which i i'm comfortable uh
for the
position of the united states
i want to thank you all for coming i
found this panel most discussion most
informative i hope you have and good
night
c-span 2 programming information is
available to our viewers 24 hours a day
for the latest schedule rundown you may
call 202
628-2205
that's current information about c-span
2